let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good afternoon everybody thanks for
joining us again
episode number 13 let's talk the
tony michaels podcast tony michaels here
got a few things to touch on today do
you think that's been going on the last
week
[Music]
some things that uh
maybe you've heard about maybe you
haven't i got a few videos i want to
play for you a few tick tocks that i
made
you guys always like my tick tock so
we'll play a few tick tocks to uh talk
about these subjects
uh the the subjects that we're gonna
touch on today
uh the one i really want to talk about
the most is uh the
derek chaven trial uh
the cop who murdered george floyd i
really want to
give a little bit of opinion on that
i've been watching a lot of the
testimony
the prosecutors questioning witnesses
and also the defense if you want to call
it that
questioning the witnesses i've watched a
lot of that
uh footage live i haven't seen every
single bit of it but i've tried to catch
the
the most pertinent parts i do want to
give my opinion
and my commentary on that today so we
will we will try to get to that subject
but before we do there's there's a few
other uh
uh a few republicans that i'd like to
uh you know talk about everyone's heard
of uh
this this florida man uh you know we got
a lot of florida man
men out there that that are in the news
and i'm not talking about the former guy
and i'm not talking about the governor
of florida well he might be tied up in
this
who i'm talking about is matt
getz everyone calls him matt gates
and it seems like the reason why they
call this guy matt
gates is because he wants me to
pronounce his
name wrong it's not spelled gates it's
spelled gets
and that's how i'm gonna say it is gets
i would think that that would piss him
off so that's good enough reason for me
to call him matt
getz keep getting corrected no it's
gates
it's gates no no no it's gets
[ __ ] them it's gets so mr matt gats we
find out last week
that mr matt gets
may have some federal crimes
that alleged federal crimes that he
committed
apparently he was having sex with an
underage girl
uh and apparently allege
allegedly he he decides to
take her across state lines to
a hotel or an event or restaurant i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
who the [ __ ] knows with this guy is this
guy really or do we have to take him
seriously i mean i've never really took
him seriously
ever since he came on the floor with the
the [ __ ]
the gas mask when covid started really
this is the person that we are supposed
to take seriously about anything give me
a [ __ ] break
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
and the hair and the and the attitude
this this this is not a serious person
then we should not be electing people
like
this in congress regardless if it's him
or marjorie taylor greene or lauren
billboard or
mo brooks or josh hawley ted cruz none
of these [ __ ]
they're just not serious people they are
not there for serious [ __ ] reasons
at all i've been talking about this the
last several weeks about policy
politicians create policy well matt gatz
doesn't even know
what the word policy means i mean
he agreed to all the iphone policy and
agreements before he
apparently uh has nude pictures that he
was showing around on
the the floor of the congress to his
other congressional mates
the other the other news out of the mad
gats scandal is this guy
with other members of congress and i
think that's really the thing that
republicans and uh
other members of congress and their
staff that that's what they're really
scared of
with this matt getz story is that
a lot of them are going to be roped into
this thing because
i mean let's face it he was supposedly
was using cash app and
apple pay to pay these people for sex
what in the i mean these people don't
even know how to crime for [ __ ] sake
number one number one if you're gonna
crying get a [ __ ]
burner if you're gonna use your cell
phone the [ __ ] are you doing and then
you pay
prostitutes and i'm not against
prostitution people
i am not against sex workers i think if
a an adult woman
wants to be have a job in the sex
industry we should protect her we should
give her the protections that any other
worker out there should get
any of them and we should stop making
them
operate in the dark and and operate
where where
[ __ ] like this can happen where they can
be taken
advantage of a woman or a man in the sex
industry
legitimately that they want to be in the
sex industry
should not have to operate in the dark
in danger
they should be able to freely operate
the way they want
if they're an adult and they're
consenting
they should be able to buy insurance
they should be able to have they should
be able to have bank accounts
but that is not the case in most states
in most states in most jurisdictions
prostitution is illegal
that's just what it is in this country
right that's right or wrong you know we
can argue that point
prostitution is illegal and
under having sex with underage
persons male or female and taking them
across state lines is
definitely definitely something that
could be construed as illegal
but mac adds is paying prostitutes on
the cash app and the apple pay app
taking miners across state lines
and it looks like it looks like he's
going to be charged with several
different charges
people are saying indictments are coming
and i would say that that's the case
and the reason why i would say that the
case is that indictments are coming
the alleged alleged indictments are
coming is because the former guy donald
trump
apparently released a statement today
saying he doesn't believe what
he doesn't believe that it's true matt
gatz
says that it's not true well
colored me surprised
that this guy is being defended
by donald trump of all people [ __ ]
grabber
i mean he's got like 28 26 28 sexual
allegations against him he still has his
dna
dna problem in new york in the state of
new york
that he's probably gonna get locked up
on
he's gonna have to give his dna
eventually
court's gonna require it
and here we have matt gatz who is
friends
with this uh county official down in
florida who is a tax
uh tax collector apparently and he's on
federal indictments they did superseding
indictments on him federal indictments
on him and added charges
my guess is see when they do stuff like
that when federal prosecutors
pressure people in a federal
investigation in a federal indictment
what they'll do is they'll charge you
with a few charges and then later on
they'll charge you with a superseding
indictment to pressure you even more
really put the pressure on to you
and what i mean put the pressure on is
to flip
to flip evidence to tell on your
co-conspirators
to give them more evidence that they may
not have or
or or confirm evidence that they have
and if the truth is that matt gatz and
this gold
gold i think his name is goldberg i
don't know who this guy is
i listen to a voicemail that they had
sent to a uh a
female opponent in a political race and
these two scuzz
bags holy [ __ ]
it it harkens back it harkens back to
the last
uh uh 2016 missouri governor's
race when eric greitens
threatened john bruner on a voicemail it
harkens back to that but it's even
creepier because it's two men
giving high brow threats to a female
candidate on the other side
it's it's on brand though
it's on brand for mad gats on brand
for sure this is the guy who decided to
pack up and go to wyoming
and campaign against the third
republican in charge liz cheney after
she voted to impeach donald trump
which she has the right to do
maybe maybe matt gatz should listen
when cheney's say [ __ ] around and find
out
this mad gas character i i had a video i
made a video about magats
not tick tock and everyone liked it um
over on tiki talk and on twitter too so
let me
let me play let me play the video i i
did about
mr gatz and his alleged
possible indictment and then we'll talk
about it on the other side
projection much let's talk yesterday
florida congressman and apparent sugar
daddy matt gatz
lets us know that he got caught up in a
federal sex trafficking case
that him and his father are flipping
evidence on his co-conspirators
he also wanted to inform us that this
person of legal age
loves to have dinner with him and tucker
carlson what the [ __ ]
political party that accuses their
opponents of being pedophiles
all the [ __ ] time you sure do have a
mess of [ __ ] chomos on your hands way
more mad gats donald [ __ ] trump
and honors i guess this is all part of
the plan huh i swear past the i'm rubber
your glue part of the plan
and have reached the takes one to no one
stage
[ __ ] them i guess that's one of the
things that uh
really captures my attention about this
uh matt getz
uh debacle here uh and it might mean
debacle because the guy hasn't resigned
yet or they haven't pushed him out yet
uh yeah i would imagine the only reason
why is because there's reports saying
that he was on the floor showing other
republican congressmen
other congress people pictures of naked
women on his phone
and there was also reports that
him and other people of congress or
other staff of congress somehow
connected the congress had a point
system
of people that they were going to have
sex with either staffers or
or married members of congress there was
a point system they were keeping track
i wonder i wonder if they were keeping
track on their cell phones
and then then yesterday we find out that
matt gatz petitioned
donald trump for not only pardons for
him is the way the report reads
not only pardons for him but pardons for
other uh
possible co-conspirators of congress i
guess and i would imagine it's the
people
he's showing pictures to on the floor
and also the point system that they were
taking
and i would imagine if he's paying for
prostitutes on the cash app and the
apple pay
that they're keeping the point system on
their cell phones i would imagine that
there's a google sheet somewhere
jesus these [ __ ] morons
it's just i can't even describe the
bonehead in this
it's so boneheaded so brazen
and of course matt gatz and some of
these other members of congress were
desperate desperate for donald trump to
become
president and it's starting to become
obvious why
and why they started to attack bill barr
at the end of the year
and decided he wasn't trumpy enough for
them
well as it turns out bill barr is open
was the one who started to open some of
these investigations
he do he was briefed
so we have a situation on our hands
where not only matt gats
but possibly other members of congress
and i can only imagine what ilk they are
you know i'm sure they're all democrats
because it turns out that the blood
sucking child
raping cabal
is not hollywood democrats
the pedophiles are on a particular side
here it seems
ridiculous so donald trump says today
oh he didn't seek a pardon
so now we know he did because donald
trump just confirmed that he did by
saying he didn't
because it's easy to know what the truth
is with donald trump it's the opposite
of what he
says it is it's very easy very simple
very cut and dry if he releases a
statement saying something
it's the opposite of that so yes
matt gatz probably more than likely
asked directly the president to his face
to pardon him for these crimes and
apparently ask for a blanket pardon
which donald trump didn't
clarify the blank blanket pardon part
but if he would have said he did not ask
for a blanket pardon
then i believe he probably did
that is how donald trump operates we
have discovered that over the last
several years
he's a lying piece of [ __ ] and when he
says something publicly especially if
he's really
willing to write it on a statement it is
probably the exact opposite that is true
so by him stating that matt gatz did not
ask for a pardon
my belief is that of course he did
the other thing that donald trump says
is the same [ __ ] he said about anybody
else or himself
well he claims the allegations are false
which when it's a republican
let's get this clear when it's a
republican it says
that the allegations they say are false
then you must believe them because that
has to be the truth because
no no way could a religious
moral christian person like matt gatz
lie
oh i can't even hardly stop myself from
laughing when those words come out of my
mouth
wow here we are
so i would imagine by the time we get to
next week's podcast which by the way
will be at wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern next week
the same time every time
here on youtube we broadcast on twitter
as well
and when we're done the the the audio
goes up on
spotify and apple now apple
that's an announcement maybe i'll talk
about that here in a minute
but next week i'm sure we will be
talking about mr getz
and i'm sure the conversation we'll be
having about mr gatz
will be if he's indicted or not because
at this point
there is no unsealed indictment
and that's the key here unsealed
indictment
now you know we can go on and on and on
about this matt gets [ __ ]
uh and all his tweets that he's tweeted
out making himself even look
more guilty by by claiming
oh it's all an uh in an
uh an attempt to embezzle money from my
father
what what it's a blackmail
scheme well someone blackmailing you
because they know about the prosecution
or the are a possible indictment doesn't
change that there's a possible
indictment
the [ __ ] does that got to do with it
so all sure i'm sure we'll continue this
mat
gets [ __ ] next week
and i'm sure there'll be plenty other
florida men tied up into this thing
and plenty other congress people that
will either
be evidence or co-conspirators in this
thing it seems like
it's what it seems like that's what it
seems like
speaking of other people in congress
these republicans have been yelling and
screaming about coca-cola every one of
them
one after the other come out and they're
gonna boycott
coca-cola and they're gonna boycott the
mlb
which honestly doesn't seem like
a good idea really i mean i mean i
i'm i'm not like against someone
boycotting coca-cola against someone
boycotting
boycotting the mlb if they want to like
if you don't want to watch baseball
fine [ __ ] it don't watch baseball you
don't want to drink coca-cola you want
to drink pepsi instead
fine [ __ ] it i know people who wouldn't
even drink coke they only drink pepsi
and i know some people that wouldn't
have a [ __ ] pepsi in their life
because they love coke
so these [ __ ] one after the
other boycott coke
don't drink coke don't watch baseball
so the list is getting longer and longer
and longer of [ __ ] these people can't do
so they they complain about these the
the vaccination passports but now
they're not even going to get to go to
these places because they're boycotting
all of them
which they aren't they're not going to
boycott them
it's all [ __ ] they're not actually
going to stop drinking coca-cola
people in georgia coca-cola is like a
[ __ ] religion for crying out loud
i mean when you go to the south and you
ask for
a soda you order a coke and they ask you
what kind because it's all
coke i got a boycott coca-cola give me a
[ __ ] break
and they're gonna boycott baseball boy
baseball fans are gonna boycott baseball
because that's how it works remember the
nfl and karen kaepernick
well we're going to boycott the nfl nfl
no longer exist because
that guy is kneeling during the national
anthem and
freedom and patriots what
the nfl survived people still watch the
nfl
it happened the nfl didn't
give a [ __ ] the mlb
doesn't give a [ __ ] frankly the more you
talk about the mlb
i think they probably like that yeah
keep us in the news
fine [ __ ] talk about the games you're
gonna boycott today tomorrow
next week on thursday there's six of
them i mean there's a ton of there's a
ton of the baseball i mean baseball
there's
there's games all day every day
it's hard to even keep up they have so
many games and apparently we're adding
nfl games that they can boycott too but
they do they have to boycott the
nfl the mlb they can't watch the nba
anymore because you know they're too
woke
they can't drink [ __ ] they can't
drink [ __ ] coca-cola
they can't go to mcdonald's they can't
even go to walmart anymore
they got walmart on the boycott list can
you imagine
can you imagine a bunch of red deck
hillbillies
going to target and buying pepsi because
[ __ ] it [ __ ] walmart's on the list
who can't go there
coca-cola so just buy pepsi like okay so
what so you bought pepsi at target who
gives a [ __ ]
what are you talking about
that's really and what's what's even
better about this whole thing and even
even more hilarious about this that they
they don't even see it
like they clearly don't even see what's
happening
they bitched and bitched and bitched for
three [ __ ] weeks about a mr potato
head not having a dick
and dr seuss not having a book
they seriously for weeks
members of congress would stand in front
of reporters with the book that wasn't
not in print
a different book than the one they were
gonna ban
ban or cancel and they would stand and
read this to reporters
the books that worked on the list
to be cancelled it's the ones they were
reading not the ones that were
the ones that weren't and they went on
and on and on and on and on
fox news and everything else jesus
christ i had to talk about it for two
weeks because they wouldn't [ __ ] shut
up about
mr potato head not having a dick not
have a genitalia potatoes
don't have genitalia
they don't have genitalia
potatoes are genitalis
jesus [ __ ] christ but we were
canceling mr potato head and dr seuss oh
it's cancer culture is the
is the enemy it's the number one threat
to
democracy and here they are this week
here they are this week calling to
cancel coca-cola
of company frankly is as american as
apple pie
because it makes us all fat and it used
to have cocaine in it
it's a fantastic company fantastic
fantastic story too makes us all walk
around like lard asses and it used to
have cocaine in it angel
dust fantastic fantastic company
fantastic company story
you don't get much more american and
having a
a bottle of fat juice that used to have
that used to have booger sugar in it
and we drink it like it's [ __ ] water
and we love it we love it
and we're gonna boycott that give me a
[ __ ] break
but it's all it's all an attempt it's
all theater
all this they invented boycotting by the
way
they invented this [ __ ] this canceled
culture which
what they're saying is cancel culture
isn't actually cancel culture and i'm
not going to get into what cancer
culture is and what it isn't today
but what they're saying is not cancel
culture with the
mr potato head and the dr seuss and
that's why
and they had a whole goddamn cpac
remember this the whole c
pack was uncanceled literally the entire
[ __ ] thing the whole week it was
uncanceled was the [ __ ] name of it
and here they are they got a whole list
of [ __ ] they got a boycott i mean a
whole [ __ ] list
and it's getting longer and longer every
goddamn day
and there's a reason why it's getting
longer and longer
it's called capitalism is the reason why
it's getting longer and longer
and that's really what i want to explain
here is
why these [ __ ] dumb shits don't
understand
that you can boycott whatever you want
that's the whole purpose of why the
companies making the claims that they
are or staking their opinion
in a certain arena is because of
capitalism
because they want more customers and
more customers equal more dollars
it's about profit people it's about
profit because if they thought that your
opinion was more profitable
they'd take your stance and it's not but
let's get into what mitch mcconnell
thought i did a little video on it and
then i'll talk to you on the other side
about it i did a little ticky talk you
know me and my tick tocks
so let's listen to that corporations are
people too
let's talk so right-wing republicans in
this country have decided that
capitalism
might not be the best system after all
cottle tells the ceos of big companies
to stay the [ __ ] out of politics
churches pillow companies and bean
canners are the only one to get to
participate in
said politics this is really on brand
for these fascists
seeing that they're against voting and
capitalism is voting
with dollars jesus [ __ ] christ i
can't believe we have to explain
capitalism to self-proclaimed free
market capitalist
freedom you dumb [ __ ] you've never been
for free market capitalism
it's called corporate fascism you [ __ ]
eating nazis
america doesn't it make you long for a
time when corporations were people too
goya beans made you fart and coca-cola
was laced with angel dust
[ __ ] them
so there's one thing i want you to take
out of that video
and the main point of the video that i
was trying to make is that
that capitalism is a form of voting
and it's a form of voting with money now
don't get it
misconstrued capitalism is not
is not a democracy it's not what it is
it's just a form of voting
that's it that's it one dollar one vote
some people got more dollars than others
it's how it works so it's a form
of voting and companies know this
company's number one job is to make
profit
to get the most votes that's what is
called profit
to get the most votes and when they
decide to make a decision
rather it's to invest in a certain
product or
to buy another business to expand
their reach and their market
rather it's to uh get rid of a certain
product because
no one's buying it or no one wants it or
maybe it's defaulty or defective
or to take a stand in a state
where there is an issue like voting
rights
and to take a stand in that state to
show people in that state where they
stand now
let's go let's let's rewind a bit
back to november when in georgia there
was a clear win for joe biden
in georgia joe biden flipped that state
from
red to blue donald trump won that state
and then he [ __ ] lost it
some would say some would argue based on
the numbers
on the special election the runoffs for
both senate seats
in the beginning of january that donald
trump
almost single-handedly ruined those
races
in georgia and those seats flipped from
red
to blue the two republican
the people who were seated were ousted
gone by the democrats
so not only did you have the
presidential race flipped from red to
blue
you had both senate runoff races which
were supposed to be a slam dunk for
these two incumbent senators they were
not
and some would surmise i would say that
donald trump
not single-handedly but had a lot to do
with them losing those races a
hell of a lot and we're probably going
to find out more about that about the
phone calls that he made to rather
burger
but that is for a different [ __ ]
podcast
now when you're coca-cola and you're
watching the the republicans
who lost in the state changed laws to
make sure
that voters in the state
can't vote because they won't vote for
republicans and trying to make it very
[ __ ] difficult
where their company is headquartered and
they're one of the biggest corporations
in the state one of the ones with one of
the biggest
sticks in the state as teddy roosevelt
would have said
they're going to have an opinion
especially
when the voters their customers
make them make a choice you either be on
the side of this thing or you don't
tell us how you feel tell us where you
stand
and we will either vote for you or vote
against you
so coca-cola made a choice and it was a
choice
purely for profit capitalism
purely for profit
that they knew they would get more votes
more money
if they were on the correct side of this
issue
and the correct side was to let people
[ __ ]
vote what is the harm in letting them
vote
rather you vote on a [ __ ] mail-in
ballot or absentee ballot or vote at the
poll or
whatever let them vote
and republicans always take these laws
way too far they always go one
step too [ __ ] far and that's what
kills because
no one no one would have really paid
attention to this law
if they wouldn't abandon giving out
water in the in the [ __ ] voting lines
if they'd have left that part out [ __ ]
this country wouldn't have paid a
[ __ ] attention to that goddamn thing
not a goddamn minute
i mean how many mass shootings have we
had already in the last month and we
have we are not even paying attention to
that
we don't pay attention in this country
we're too goddamned distracted
by everything else they wouldn't have
noticed hey it would have been a
headline
had been on the news for a couple days
people wouldn't pay attention but
because they outlawed water they took it
one step one step too far i mean
the dumbest thing in the world that you
can't can someone you make it illegal to
hand someone a bottle of water
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
how dumb can you be florida apparently
has a law that
or they're trying to pass a bill that is
very similar
to the snack ban
in georgia but that was their mistake
and everyone's paying attention and
coca-cola frankly is a beverage company
and they have dasani water
dasani water so of course they have a
vested interest
in water being passed out on voting
lines
a financial vested interest of water and
snacks being passed out on voting lines
coca-cola has
so of course they're against this
[ __ ] law
for that fact alone other than you're
taking the rights away from people
now we go to the mlb in the all-star
game
and i know that right-wingers are
talking about oh
well colorado's laws are almost the same
[ __ ]
well that's the mlb's problem that's
what you [ __ ] don't understand
that's the mlb's problem
not your problem if you don't want to
watch the game don't watch the [ __ ]
game
if you want to watch the game in the
home run derby and all that [ __ ]
then watch it
if you don't don't don't go the games
don't watch the games don't buy the [ __ ]
they advertise on the games
fine i don't think you're gonna do that
it's all [ __ ] but okay whatever
whatever you want to do
but the truth is is that colorado has a
hell of a lot
more ballot access than georgia would
ever dream of
at this point they literally send an
application to a hundred percent of
registered voters
for mail-in ballots the things that you
[ __ ] hate
so if you want to switch if you
[ __ ] want to switch the laws in
georgia to be like colorado
be my guest you will [ __ ] lose
from now until kingdom come in georgia
if they do that
that's why you don't want to do that is
because if they change the laws that way
you won't win
because more votes equals republicans
losing and it's obvious that's what
you're doing
everyone knows it even the mlb in
coca-cola and delta airlines
knows you're doing that
they know it you know it that's why
they're doing what they're doing
you dumb [ __ ]
so spare me the [ __ ] [ __ ] mitch
mcconnell about how
corporations and and companies should
stay out of politics
all the while in the same sentence you
say well i'm not talking about
political contributions
which again we could do a whole nother
podcast on citizens united and
mitch mcconnell's stance on citizens
united and how that
piece of [ __ ] garbage would
would prefer that voters stay out of
politics
and let money dictated because that's
what he wants
ultimately that's what he would desire
is for money to dictate politics not
voters
again listen up knuckleheads
capitalism is a system of voting it's
not democracy
but it's a system of voting and it
really is on brand
it really is on brand that republicans
who hate [ __ ] voting
seem to hate capitalism and they've
always hated capitalism they pretend to
like it
they pretend to like capitalism what
they really like is corporate fascism
that's what they really like
if you don't know what the [ __ ]
corporate fashion is fascism is
go get on your google machine and look
that [ __ ] up because that's what it is
and that's what they love
now i want to move on here to another
subject that
i believe is very very important
something that has been happening over
the last
several days and that is all the
testimony that has become
been coming in on the derek javen trial
for the murder of
george floyd where he kneeled on his
neck for what we find out to be over
nine minutes not under nine minutes over
nine minutes
and snuffing the air out of his lungs
and the life out of his body
there's a lot of stuff to unpack because
there's a lot of testimony and again
i haven't watched every single minute of
the testimony but i've tried to catch
uh each witness i've tried to catch
several questions
by the prosecution and the defense of
each witness
so that i can see have a clear picture
of what this trial looks like
so let me i i did a i did a uh
a tick tock of course i did a tick tock
on this so uh let me play that
i was going to talk about a little in
advance but let me go ahead and play the
video that i did
uh on the trial and really it's not more
about the trial as it is about the
commentary of the trial that was
happening
uh over the last several days um this
this commentary has started to
die off because the fence is not doing
themselves any justice here
and this argument of the overdo overdose
is uh beginning to fade away and they're
they're hanging on to
even flimsier argument about about the
crowd and the bystanders but
let me play this video that i did and
i'll we'll talk about this on the other
side
death penalty what the [ __ ]
let's talk apparently there's some [ __ ]
bags in this country that think if a
person has a drug in their system
that warrants the death sentence you
dumb [ __ ]
really the case or is it that the person
who has drugs in their system
happens to be black hey your crusty
white grapple is about to have back
surgery and for the pain he's prescribed
some [ __ ] opioids
stoked up one morning walks into a
convenience store and happens to pass a
fake 20
bill show up they try to get grandpa on
the back of the cruiser and because of
his
prescription paranoia he doesn't want to
go in right thing to do with these [ __ ]
bags mind is to throw grandpa on the
ground and kneel on him until he's dead
because he was gonna die anyways we say
that the death of the krusty white
grandpa was justified i didn't think so
stop beating around the bush you [ __ ]
you think george floyd should have died
because he's black
you racist [ __ ] [ __ ] him
so i was trying to make the point there
because i i kept seeing in comments and
feeds and threads
this this this worn out argument of how
george floyd was gonna die anyways
because he had opioids in his system
number one that that is not what the
autopsy says
not even close and if it if it was what
the autopsy says we wouldn't have a
a murder trial uh that
derek shaman would be facing if it was
deemed an accident
we wouldn't have one it was rule the
homicide meaning a person killed a
person
he had drugs in the system he was a drug
user he he
he had an addiction to opioids a lot of
people do
white people black people
a lot of people of all different races
and colors and creeds and backgrounds
incomes have drug addictions
a lot of people do drugs some people
recreationally
some people are prescribed drugs and
they have an addiction don't even know
it and that's the kind of the point i
was trying to make in the video
is that this idea because a person has
drugs in their system
that a police officer has has the
ability and the right
and the know-how in other words they
know that that person is on drugs
and they know that that person is going
to die they have this
this keen sense of when that person is
going to die from the drugs that are in
their system or some stupid [ __ ]
i don't know what these people the the
[ __ ] marbles that are rolling around
their head how they
convince themselves of these arguments
but somehow that is a justification
to hold a human being down on the ground
and snuff every single ounce of oxygen
out of their lungs and kill them kill
them in less than 10 minutes
doesn't matter i don't care what your
age is
again i was i was i was forming up
intentionally to an old white man
because if there was a video of an old
white man who was on opioids that came
out of a convenience store that happened
to possibly pass a fake twenty dollar
bill knowingly or unknowingly the cops
show up
they put him on the ground and they pin
him on the ground until he's dead
i would say that there was gonna be some
[ __ ] outrage
especially if it was videoed and people
around like hey you're killing the old
dude
get off of him
but in this case in this case because
george floyd is black these people are
trying to make the argument that he was
gonna die
anyways his life is [ __ ] useless
that's what they're saying
they're trying to pull the [ __ ]
humanity out of it
they're trying to dehumanize him and
make him into some sort of
demon because he had drugs or did drugs
and most of these people making this
argument probably are on drugs
it's ridiculous it's a ridiculous
argument
it doesn't even it doesn't even pass the
[ __ ] smell test
but the prosecution boy the prosecution
was really trying to work with it
they're really trying to mold it are not
the prosecution the defense excuse me
the defense
his defense was really trying to work it
really trying to mold that argument that
it was the drugs it was the drugs
and the one the one key witness that
that kind of smashed all this drug thing
to pieces was
was george fuloid's girlfriend or former
girlfriend
when they tried to made her into the
demon too like somehow
she was at fault uh that that this cop
kneel on his neck
and killed him because she knew where he
got the drug so it was her fault or some
[ __ ]
that's one thing i'll say about this
trial is the defense
is not that great i don't know where he
found this lawyer
it doesn't matter what his name is this
lawyer i don't know where he found him
and i don't know how much experience he
has in murder trials but it doesn't seem
like a lot
doesn't even seem like he has a lot of
experience in making arguments
because he can't decide whether he wants
to blame the murder of george floyd or
the death of george floyd on george
floyd's
drug addiction or the bystanders in the
crowd
because that's a narrative they're
really trying to mold and work too is
oh the reason why derek shavin had to
kill
george floyd is because the crowd was
loud
and they had their cameras on and they
were telling
the the police officers that george
floyd would couldn't breathe
and he was dying which turned out to be
the [ __ ] truth
so because people were standing there
telling him loudly and aggressively or
whatever you want to call it
because they were standing there filming
saying this stuff that's the reason why
derek
chavin had to kill him what
so either he was gonna die of an
overdose or it was the crowd's fault
it's very clear that that the defense is
trying to find
trying to find the nugget
that the jury will believe and the
reason why it seems kind of
awkward to us i think is because we
actually don't
get to see the jury we don't get to see
the reactions to these arguments that
he's making
are trying to make which he's not doing
a very goddamn good job
because there's been a lot of these
witnesses that he questions them and he
clearly wants a certain answer and the
witness gives a different answer than he
was expecting
and that should be like 101 of trial
attorneys especially defense attorneys
do not ask the question you don't want
the answer to
but he keeps doing it with every witness
keeps walking right into it
i don't know intentionally
unintentionally some people are
surmising that
maybe maybe they're trying to you know
paint this up a certain way
but the reports that we are getting from
the press that are inside the courtroom
are that the jury is not buying any of
this [ __ ]
now we don't get to see that we don't
get to see the reaction the jury
on camera we just get to see the the
prosecution the defense questions
we get to see the judge speaking we get
to see the witness in their statements
and then we get to see the evidence
that's presented to the court published
in the court
that's what we get to see but this
defense
boy if you call it that now now that the
one reason why the defense is not very
good is because
there's just not much to defend there
they keep going back to one little clip
in the video
one little clip mean there's tons
of video here tons of video but the
one moment he keeps going back to
is right before they roll
george floyd's dead body over on its
side
after that he's been on top of him for
almost 10 minutes on his
neck with his leg
the defense is trying to argue in that
one clip in that one moment
his leg may maybe on his shoulder
a little bit well of course it's on his
[ __ ]
shoulder his shoulders connected to his
goddamn
neck and your leg is connected to your
[ __ ] knee
so when you got your knee into someone's
[ __ ] neck your leg is
gonna graze the person's shoulder
so their argument is is that unless the
knee is directly on the neck and only on
the neck
and only in that spot where where it
would kill someone
then that's what makes it murder
anything else any other variation
is not murder because you know your leg
bones connect to your knee bone your
knee bones connect to your leg bone of
course
of course his [ __ ] leg is touching
george floyd's shoulder
of course it is his knee is on his
neck which is connected to his [ __ ]
shoulders and the knee
is connected to the leg it's not rocket
science
and then this argument of where the neck
is and where it starts and where it ends
they keep saying well it's not on the
neck it's on the lower neck
oh well you know in a murder trial where
someone shot
directly in the neck that's the murder
but when you're shot in the lower neck
ah it's questionable that's questionable
if you're shot in the lower neck
as opposed to directly in the neck you
[ __ ] break
this is their best defense because it's
indefensible he
murdered george floyd we all watched it
we can all see it
that's what happened he got mad when he
got there because george floyd didn't
want to go in the patrol car
he knew who george floyd was he didn't
like george floyd
he pulled george floyd out of the car
they proceeded to put him on the ground
when they were on him for almost 10
minutes and the crowd
was agitated because they were killing
him because they were
he got more agitated and he wanted to
show his power
he wanted to show the ability that he
had and he wanted to show that crowd
what he could get away with
that's it that's what's becoming clear
with this trial this
nonsense about how his his knee was on
his
lower neck and his leg touched his
shoulder when he got up
you can see from this vantage point that
his leg is near his shoulder
of course it is his leg is near george
floyd's shoulder
he had his knee on his neck right after
he that's how he
murdered him is with his knee on his
neck
well it's on the lower neck you know the
lower neck regions of the regions of the
it's on his neck
you can tell that i've been watching
this trial and you can tell
that i have a certain opinion about the
trial and it's turning out
it's turning out that justice may be
served because it doesn't
there's no clear there is no clear path
for the defense
nah to make a good case here why why
derek shavin was in the was in the right
to use the force that he used
the deadly force that he used because
that's the other thing that is appearing
with these witnesses in this trial
is that not only not only was uh was
derek chavin's
methods and tactics that he used
probably
unlawful in other words the knee on the
neck
that maneuver was probably unlawful but
not only that that george floyd's
actions did not justify that
that extent of force the force of
of rendering him unconscious and killing
him
right there on the spot because if you
watch the video
and and even even several of the
witnesses when they
give their testimony of the video when
they roll
george floyd's dead body over to try to
get him on the gurney
after derek chavin's knee has killed
george floyd they even say
well of course he's unconscious he looks
dead
not in so many words but that's what
these witnesses have testified to
he looks he looks dead because he was
he did not have a pulse he was not
breathing
by all standards that is not alive
when they rolled him over
when george floyd went on the ground he
was alive
and when derek javen got up and got his
knee off
george floyd's neck he was dead
and he died of asphyxiation
so good luck to the defense to defend
that
because i think that's what's going on
and really honestly
uh this this defense lawyer every time
he asked a question
he looks more and more terrified that of
course his of course his client is
guilty and of course his clients going
to prison
they're just trying to see if they can
maneuver their way into
getting two of the charges dropped which
the more and more it looks like it looks
like the of course this was an assault
derrick chavin intended to hurt george
floyd with this maneuver
with the time and the effort that he
gave to
give this maneuver the knee on the neck
which is not an approved maneuver by the
minneapolis police or
police departments anywhere apparently
that's what the testimony that's
being that's that's being said
and not only that he wasn't trained to
do it this way
he was not trained to do this maneuver
that mr
chavin is is in a lot of trouble here
and he should be
he used his power to kill someone
so i will probably talk about this trial
more next week because uh we've got
seven days now this trial may tick on
for a couple more weeks so
i'm sure we'll get some more commentary
we'll have more testimony
and we're gonna get to the defense's
witnesses uh to see if they can change
the hearts and minds of the jury which
i i seriously doubt that will happen
to see the testimony that's already been
wrought
uh one after another after another
police officer has no real good defense
of the maneuver that derek chavin used
nor the time that he used it the amount
of time that he used it
testimony is yes you can get someone
down in a prone position
but as soon as they are they are
prone and and restrained you roll them
over
and the reason why you roll them over is
to make sure they can breathe because
you can injure them or kill them
and you do not put their knee on their
neck you put it on their back
that's the testimony now rather that
maneuver is correct or not
back or neck i i i think that's a
decision we need to make in this country
but that is the testimony
so i will leave it there for now and
i i hope i hope we come to uh
a conclusion within the next week on
this this trial i hope
uh the the evidence is enough to
get a conclusion and and and get the
final statements of the defense and the
prosecutor
uh so that way we can um
we can uh hopefully see what justice
will be done
uh for george floyd's family
but also to start to
uh figure out how to heal the wound in
the nation
um not not not just of george floyd's
death but
uh this nonsense of of how uh
for police officers to discredit
the humanity of people regardless
if they're black white
male female they've got drugs in their
system they don't have
drugs in their system they're human
beings they should be treated that way
you should not have the power of judge
jury and executioner on the ground
in front of a convenience store right
next to your patrol car
you should not have that power but they
think they do and that's the problem
they think they do so
for the family members of george floyd i
hope they get justice here it appears
that
that trajectory is on its way and i hope
we can heal these
wounds which it's going to take a long
time and a lot of work for work long
time and a lot of work this is not going
to happen overnight there's a hell of a
lot of police departments in this
country
some of them good most of them uh have
bad policy on this
and we need we need to fix that
we need to figure out how that happens
and have the conversation
but i appreciate you joining me this
afternoon
and join me next week wednesday at three
o'clock four o'clock central right here
on youtube or twitter we
we stream on twitter now but if you miss
it live it's okay don't worry
don't worry we put it it gets recorded
on youtube so you can watch it
and and then it and then we put it up on
spotify and apple podcast once it's
recorded
now last week's episode number 12 uh
youtube actually took down you know
because we have controversial material
here
and they they took the video down i'm
still in the appeal process
but episode 12 still is on spotify it's
still on apple podcast if you want to go
listen to it over there
hopefully we will come to some
conclusion of why they took the video
down specifically what i said
and hopefully it will come to some
conclusion on the appeal and get episode
12 back up for you guys to listen and to
watch
but until next time until next time
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them